I had built a business out of force of
personality I was in every meeting made
every decision I was Chief cook and
bottle washer and when you start to have
some success even just a little bit of
scale that doesn't work I reached a
Peter Principle where my ability to
build structure capped out the single
best lesson I learned out of that whole
experience was I don't have to know
everything and I don't have to pretend I
do and so I'm really good at saying I
don't know and I need help now and don't
build anything by myself and don't feel
I have to I don't feel like have to be
the smartest person in the room I don't
feel like I have to have more
credibility than anybody else I don't
mind any of those things I let go of all
of that baggage and a lot of us still
carry that baggage that we think if
we're in the leaders we have to have all
the answers we have to be the smartest
person we have to be better at everybody
else's job than they are because that's
what makes us a leader and we falsely
confuse our credibility as a leader is
not tied to our intelligence it's tied
to our ability to see those around us
rise that's what it means to be a
[Music]
leader